♪♪
YOU'VE HEARD OF A DRONE.
THAT'S ACTUALLY
THE COLLOQUIAL NAME
FOR AN UNMANNED AERIAL VEHICLE.
THE LATEST IN DRONE TECHNOLOGY
IS AN OCTOCOPTER.
IT IS THIS HUGE BADASS
FLYING SPIDER THING
WITH EIGHT PROPELLERS
AND IT IS QUICK
AND IT HAS THESE STATE-
OF-THE-ART FLIGHT CONTROLS
AND IT IS SO FUN TO FLY.
Narrator: THE PRECISE
ENGINEERING OF THE ARMS
CAN BE SEEN IN OUR TEST LAB.
EACH ARM IS DESIGNED
WITH AN EIGHT-DEGREE INVERSION,
MEANING, INSTEAD
OF BEING HORIZONTALLY LEVEL,
IT'S SET AT A SLIGHT
VERTICAL ANGLE,
AND THERE'S A GOOD REASON
FOR THIS.
IF THE ARMS WERE
COMPLETELY HORIZONTAL
AND PROPELLERS
POINTED STRAIGHT DOWN,
YOU'D GET UNSTABLE
FLIGHT CHARACTERISTICS.
BUT BECAUSE THE AIR
IS PUSHED SLIGHTLY OUT,
THE PRESSURE PUSHES THE DRONE
IN ON ITSELF, KEEPING IT STABLE.
AT THE END OF EACH ARM,
THERE IS A FIVE-INCH,
HIGH-STRENGTH,
HIGH-PERFORMANCE
PLASTIC PROPELLER,
AND THESE ARE WHAT
GIVES THE DRONE ITS LIFT.
THESE DRONES DEFINITELY
HAVE PERSONALITIES.
YOU SEE THE DRONE,
YOU'RE LIKE,
"WHAT IS IT THINKING?"
IF YOU WANT THE DRONE
TO ROTATE,
YOU INCREASE THE POWER
TO THE PROPELLERS
ROTATING IN ONE DIRECTION
AND DECREASE THE POWER
TO THE OTHERS.
WHAT'S REALLY COOL
IS THAT EACH ARM
HAS ITS OWN MOTOR BUILT
INTO THE PROPELLER,
SO IF ONE OF THEM FAILS,
IT CAN STILL CONTINUE TO FLY.
THOSE MOTORS EACH HAVE
A LIFT POWER OF 10 POUNDS,
MEANING THAT THE ENTIRE
DRONE CAN LIFT
25 ADDITIONAL POUNDS,
IN ADDITION TO ITS OWN WEIGHT.
THE LANDING GEAR
ON YOUR OCTOCOPTER
IS 18 INCHES LONG
AND IT'S ALSO RETRACTABLE,
JUST LIKE THE LANDING GEAR
ON A COMMERCIAL AIRCRAFT.
AND WHEN IT LANDS,
IT'S SO FUNNY.
IT PUTS OUT THESE LITTLE LEGS
AND THEN IT, LIKE, POLITELY
JUST, LIKE, PLIéS ON THE GROUND.
THE CORE OF A DRONE
IS THE FLIGHT CONTROLLER.
THIS IS THE BRAINS
OF THE OPERATION.
Narrator: THE FLIGHT CONTROLLER
IS A CIRCUIT BOARD
THAT MEASURES GPS POSITION,
ATMOSPHERIC CONDITIONS,
AND WIND SPEED.
THESE DRONES HAVE INCREDIBLY
SENSITIVE FLIGHT CONTROLLERS
THAT CAN HELP COMPENSATE
FOR THINGS THEY MIGHT ENCOUNTER.
SAY A GUST OF WIND BLOWS
TOO HARD ON THE RIGHT SIDE,
IT'LL COMPENSATE
AND KEEP IT STEADY.
SAY ONE OF THE PROPELLERS
GOES OUT,
IT CAN COMPENSATE
AND STILL KEEP IT IN THE AIR.
YOU CAN ALSO PLAN A FLIGHT PATH
SO THAT IT'S LITERALLY GONNA
FOLLOW YOUR INSTRUCTIONS
AND USE THAT GPS,
IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO FIGURE
OUT WHERE TO GO. YOU KNOW,
YOU CAN HAVE, LITERALLY,
A DRONE FOLLOW YOU LIKE A PET.
SO YOU CAN ESSENTIALLY BE
ON YOUR MOUNTAIN BIKE,
FLYING AROUND THE MOUNTAINS,
DOING COOL STUFF,
LOOKING LIKE A BADASS.
AND THEN THE DRONE'S
JUST FOLLOWING YOU,
TAKING VIDEO THE WHOLE TIME.
IT'S RAD.
THE FLIGHT CONTROLLER
ALSO INCLUDES AN IMU,
OR INERTIA MANAGEMENT UNIT,
AND THAT INCLUDES A GYROSCOPE
AND 12 OTHER SENSORS
THAT HELP KEEP
THAT DRONE STABLE AND LEVEL.